from the amazing results and vintage
Atari games deep Minds victory with
alphago stunning breakthroughs in
robotic arm manipulation and even
beating professional players at 1v1 dota
the field of reinforcement learning has
literally exploded in recent years ever
since the impressive breakthrough on the
imagenet classification challenge in
2012 the successes of supervised deep
learning have continued to pile up and
people from many different backgrounds
have started using deep neural nets to
solve a wide range of new tasks
including how to learn intelligent
behavior in complex dynamic environments
so in this episode I will give a general
introduction into the field of
reinforcement learning as well as an
overview of the most challenging
problems that we're facing today if
you're looking for a solid introduction
into the field of deep reinforcement
learning then this episode is exactly
what you're looking for my name is
Xander and welcome to archive insights
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so in its 2017 Peter Emil gave a very
inspiring demo in front of a large
audience of some of the brightest minds
in AI and machine learning so you showed
this video where a robot is cleaning a
living room bringing somebody a bottle
of beer and basically doing a whole
range of mundane tasks that robots in
sci-fi movies can do without question
and then at the end of the video peter
revealed that the robots actions were
actually entirely remote-controlled by a
human operator and the takeaway from
this demo I think is a very important
one it basically says that the robots
we've been building for decades now are
physically perfectly capable of doing a
wide range of useful tasks but the
problem is that we can't embed them with
the needed intelligence to do those
things so basically creating useful
state-of-the-art robotics is a software
challenge and not a hardware problem and
so it turns out that having a robot
learn how to do something very simple
like picking up a bottle of beer can be
a very challenging task and so in this
video I want to introduce you guys to
the whole subfield in machine learning
that's called reinforcement learning
which i think is one of the most
promising directions to actually get to
very intelligent
robotic behavior so in the most common
machine learning applications people use
what we call supervised learning and
this means that you give an input to
your neural network model but you know
the output that your model should
produce and therefore you can compute
gradients using something like the back
propagation algorithm to train that
network to produce your outputs so
imagine you want to train a neural
network to play the game of pong what
you would do in a supervised setting is
you would have a good human gamer play
the game of pong for a couple of hours
and you would create a data set where
you log all of the frames that that
human is seeing on the screen as well as
the actions that he takes in response to
those frames so whatever is pushing the
up arrow or the down arrow and we can
then feed those input frames through a
very simple neural network that at the
output can produce two simple actions
it's either going to select the up
action or the down action and by simply
training on the data set of the human
gameplay using something like back
propagation we can actually train that
neural network to replicate the actions
of the human gamer but there are two
significant downsides to this approach
so on the one hand if you want to do
supervised learning you have to create a
data set to train on which is not always
a very easy thing to do and on the other
hand if you train your neural network
model to simply imitate the actions of
the human player well then by definition
your agent can never be better at
playing the game of pong than that human
gamer for example if you want to train a
neural net to be better at playing the
game of gold and the best human then by
definition we can't use supervised
learning so is there a way to have an
agent learn to play a game entirely by
itself well fortunately there is and
this is called reinforcement learning so
the framework and reinforcement learning
is actually surprisingly similar to the
normal framework in supervised learning
so we still have an input frame we run
it through some neural network model and
the network produces an output action we
either up or down but the only
difference here is that now we don't
actually know the target label so we
don't know in any situation whether we
should have gone up or down because we
don't have a data set to train on and in
reinforcement learning the network that
transforms input frames to output
actions is called the policy Network now
one of the simplest ways to train a
policy network is
a method called policy gradients so the
approach in policy gradients is that you
start out with a completely random
network you feed that network a frame
from the game engine it produces a
random up with action you know either up
or down you send that action back to the
game engine and the game engine produces
the next frame and this is how the loop
continues and the network in this case
it could be a fully connected network
but you can obviously apply convolutions
there as well and now in reality the
output of your network is going to
consist of two numbers the probability
of going up and the probability of going
down and what you will do while training
is actually sample from the distribution
so that you're not always going to
repeat the same exact actions and this
will allow your agent to sort of explore
the environment a bit randomly and
hopefully discover better rewards and
better behavior now importantly because
we want to enable our agent to learn
entirely by itself the only feedback
that we're gonna give it is the
scoreboard in the game so whenever our
agent manages to score a goal it will
receive a reward of +1 and if the
opponent scored a goal then our agent
will receive a penalty of minus 1 and
the entire goal of the agent is to
optimize its policy to receive as much
reward as possible so in order to train
our policy network the first thing we're
gonna do is collect a bunch of
experience so you're just gonna run a
whole bunch of those game frames through
your network select random actions feed
them back into the engine and just
create a whole bunch of random pong
games and now obviously since our agent
hasn't learned anything useful yet it's
gonna lose most of those games but the
thing is that sometimes our agent might
get lucky sometimes it's going to
randomly select a whole sequence of
actions that actually lead to scoring a
goal and in this case our agent is going
to receive a reward and a key thing to
understand is that for every episode
regardless of whether we want a positive
or a negative reward we can already
compute the gradients that would make
the actions that our agents has chosen
more likely in the future and this is
very crucial and so what policy
gradients are going to do is that for
every episode where we've got a positive
reward we're going to use the normal
gradients to increase the probability of
those actions in the future but whenever
we got a negative
we're gonna apply the same gradient but
we're gonna multiply it with minus one
and this minus sign will make sure that
in the future all the actions that we
took in a very bad episode are going to
be less likely in the future and so the
result is that while training our policy
network the actions that lead to
negative rewards are slowly going to be
filtered out and the actions that leads
to positive rewards are going to become
more and more likely so in a sense our
agent is learning how to play the game
of pong now I know this was a very quick
introduction to reinforcement learning
so if you want to read up a bit and
spend a little bit more time in thinking
about the details
I really recommend to read and rake
carpet these blog post pong from pixels
it does a phenomenal job at explaining
all the details all right so we can use
policy gradients to train a neural
network to play the game of pong that's
amazing right well yes it is but as
always there are a few very significant
downsides to using this methods let's go
back to pong one more time so imagine
that your agent has been training for a
while and it's actually doing a pretty
decent job at playing the game of pong
it's bouncing the ball back and forth
but then at the end of the episode it
makes a mistake it lets the ball through
and it gets a negative penalty so the
problem with policy gradients is that
our policy gradient is going to assume
that since we lost that episode all of
the actions that we took there must be
bad actions and is going to reduce the
likelihood of taking those actions in
the future but remember that actually
the most part of that episode we were
doing really well so we don't really
want to decrease the likelihood of those
actions and in reinforcement learning
this is called the credit assignment
problem
it's where if you get a reward at the
end of your episode well what are the
exact actions that led to that specific
reward and this problem is entirely
related to the fact that we have what we
call a sparse reward setting so instead
of getting a reward for every single
action we only get a reward after an
entire episode and our agent needs to
figure out what part of its action
sequence we're causing the reward that
it eventually gets so in the case of
punk for example our agent should learn
that it's only the actions right before
it hits the ball that are truly
important everything else once the ball
is flying off it doesn't really matter
for the eventual reward and so the
result of this sparse reward setting is
that in reinforcement learning
algorithms are typically very sample
inefficient which means that you have to
give them a ton of training time before
they can learn some useful behavior and
I've made a previous video to compare
the sample efficiency of reinforcement
learning algorithms with human learning
that goes much deeper into why this is
the case and now it turns out that in
some extreme cases the sparse reward
setting actually fails completely so a
famous example is the game Montezuma's
Revenge where the goal of the agent is
to navigate a bunch of ladders jump over
a skull grab a key and then actually
navigate to the door - in order to get
to the next level and the problem here
is that by taking random actions your
agent is never gonna see a single reward
because you know the sequence of actions
that it needs to take to get that reward
is just too complicated it's never gonna
get there with random actions and so
your policy gradient is never gonna see
a single positive reward so it has no
idea what to do in the same case applies
to robotic control where for example you
would like to train in robotic arm to
pick up an object and stack it onto
something else
well the typical robot has about seven
joints that it can move so it's a
relatively high action space and if you
only give it a positive reward when it's
actually successfully stacked a block
well by doing random exploration it's
never gonna get to see any of that
reward and I think it's important to
compare this with the traditional
supervised deep learning successes that
we get into something like computer
vision for example so the reason
computer vision works so well is that
for every single input frame you have a
target label and this lets you do very
efficient gradient descent with
something like back propagation whereas
in a reinforcement learning setting
you're having to deal with this very big
problem of sparse reward setting and
this is why you know computer vision is
showing some very impressive results
while something is simple as stacking
one block onto another
seems very difficult even for
state-of-the-art woodland
[Music]
and so the traditional approach to solve
this issue of sparse rewards has been
the use of rewards shaping so reward
chipping is the process of manually
designing a reward function that needs
to guide your policy to some desired
behavior so in the case of montezuma's
revenge for example you could give your
agent a reward every single time it
manages to avoid the skull or reach the
key and these extra rewards will guide
your policy to some desired behavior and
while this obviously makes it easier for
your policy to converge to desired
behavior there are some significant
downsides to reward shaping so firstly
reward shaping is a custom process that
needs to be redone for every new
environment you want to train a policy
so if you're looking at the benchmark of
Atari for example well you would have to
craft a new reward function for every
single one of those games that's just
not scalable the second problem is that
we Ward shaping suffers from what we
call the alignment problem so it turns
out that reward shaping is actually
surprisingly difficult in a lot of cases
when you when you shape your reward
function your agent will find some very
surprising way to make sure that it's
getting a lot of reward but not doing at
all what you wanted to do and in a sense
the policy is just overfitting to that
specific reward function that you
designed
while not generalizing to the intended
behavior that you had in mind and
there's a lot of funny cases where
reward shaping goes terribly wrong so
here for example the agent was trained
to do jumping and the reward function
was the distance from its feet to the
ground and what this agent has learned
is to simply grow a very tall body and
do some kind of a backflip to make sure
that its feet are very far from the
ground to give you one final idea of how
hard it can be to the reward shaping I
mean look at this shaped reward function
for a robotic control task I don't even
want to know how long the people from
this paper spent on designing this
specific reward function to get the
behavior that they wanted and finally in
some cases like alphago for example by
definition you don't want to do any
reward shaping because this will
constrain your policy to the behavior of
humans which is not exactly optimal in
every situation so the situation that
we're in right now is that we know that
it's really hard to train in a sparsely
setting but at the same time it's also
very tricky to shape a reward function
and we don't always want to do that and
to end this video I would like to note
that a lot of media stories picture
reinforcement learning as some kind of a
magical AI sauce that lets the agent
learn on itself or improve upon its
previous version but the reality is that
most of these breakthroughs are actually
the work of some of the brightest minds
alive today and there's a lot of very
hard engineering going on behind the
scenes so I think that one of the
biggest challenges in navigating our
digital landscape is discerning truth
from fiction in this ocean of clickbait
that is powered by the advertisement
industry and I think the Atlas robot
from Boston Dynamics is a very clear
example of what I mean so I think if you
go out on the streets and you ask a
thousand people with the most advanced
robots today are well they would
probably point to Atlas from Boston
Dynamics because everybody has seen the
video where it does a backflip but the
reality is that if you think about
what's what Boston Dynamics is actually
doing well it's very likely that there's
not a lot of deep learning going on
there if you look at their previous
papers in the research track record well
they're they're doing a lot of very
advanced robotics don't get me wrong but
there's not a lot of self driven
behavior there's not a lot of
intelligent decision-making going on in
those robots so don't get me wrong
Boston Dynamics is a very impressive
robotics company but the media images
they've created might be a little bit
confusing to a lot of people that don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
but nonetheless if you look at the
progress of research that is going on I
think we should not be negligible of the
potential risks that these technologies
can bring so I think it's very good that
a lot more people are getting involved
in the whole a AI safety research
because this is going to become very
fundamental threats like autonomous
weapons and mass surveillance are to be
taken very seriously and so the only
hope we have is that international law
is going to be somewhat able to keep up
with the rapid progress we see in
technology but on the other hand I also
feel like the media is focusing way too
much on the negative side of these
technologies simply because people fear
what they don't understand and well fear
sells more advertisement than utopias so
I personally believe that most if not
all technological progress is beneficial
in the long run
as long as we can make sure that there
are no monopolies that can maintain or
enforce their power with the malignant
use of AI well anyway enough politics
for one video so this video was an
introduction into deep reinforcement
learning and an overview of the most
challenging problems that we're facing
in the field in the next video I will
dive into some of the most recent
approaches that try to tackle these
problems of sample efficiency and the
sparse reward setting so specifically I
will cover a few technical papers
dealing with approaches like auxilary or
reward settings intrinsic curiosity
hindsight experience replay and so on
I've also seen that a few people have
chosen to support me on patreon for
which I would just like to say thank you
very much I mean it really means a big
deal to me I'm doing these videos
completely in my spare time and knowing
that there's people out there that
appreciate this content really feels
great so thank you very much thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
I'd love to see you again in the next
episode of archived insights
you